welcome to Sapienza 47
the second episode of hitman opens with
agent 47 lounging on a bench in the
idyllic vacation destination
stop piensa with a newspaper in hand and
a crisp Italian shirt on his back you
could be forgiven for mistaking agent 47
as a proxy of daniel craig's James Bond
if it wasn't for his shaved and
bar-coded head sapiens as laid-back
atmosphere is almost the antithesis of
the first episodes bustling fashion show
and the shift comes as a breath of fresh
air there's a great variety of events to
behold and more ground to cover and
you're afforded more opportunities to
explore unfettered by potential threats
on the streets while exploring to
familiarize yourself with the area
you'll regularly stumble into amusing
scenes and personalities whether it's a
street performer entertaining a group of
tourists and off-duty waiter taking a
leak or a priest who's flustered to see
you barge into the middle of a
confession
there are numerous vignettes that made
me snicker and buy into the idea that
Sapienza is a functioning community
good put some pants on your mission in
this episode is to infiltrate a
sprawling villa kill two targets and
destroy an experimental virus located in
the heart of an underground lab in
traditional hitman fashion their
disguises to steal from unsuspecting
NPCs that allow you to pass through
security checkpoints in full hired hands
into thinking you're just another
employee toiling away in the opulent
estate hunting for opportunities in your
environment is just as critical to the
hitman experience as the act of
assassinating targets you spend most of
your time sneaking and procuring useful
items and while you need to be ever
vigilant to avoid detection from
suspicious NPCs hit man's unreliable AI
can be easily fooled once you learn how
to manipulate the way the game handles
line of sight it's reasonable to expect
that rounding a corner and making a
sharp turn in an unexpected direction
would throw off a hapless guard but it's
a little silly that you can avoid
detection by crouching and walking
circles around objects despite that
agent 47s head is poking out in plain
view
anyone who played the first episode will
feel right at home here and potentially
more at ease where the mansion in Paris
was brimming with people and stuffed
with hallways and tiny rooms Sapienza
has more open space and this looser
layout potentially presents fewer hiding
places with no crowds to confuse guards
and fewer windows to jump into and out
of
but this also makes the moment-to-moment
action feel more manageable the
underground laboratory is a totally
different beast compared to the manager
it's small and jam-packed with
professional security and doctors in a
space that's only big enough for a few
medical trailers and wooden crates it's
a scene that's tough to navigate and
even harder to crack but it's
concentrated nature makes victory all
the more rewarding with a swap of an
outfit an arrant keycard and a handy
hazmat suit you can make it into the
virus's containment facility but it
requires extreme patience any amount of
aggressive behavior in the lab is met
with extreme force though you can still
rely on hit man's forgiving radar meets
map which automatically tracks movements
of targets and NPCs you can use
infiltration and reconnaissance across
the entirety of Sapienza to locate your
targets NPC is often engage in
conversations that reveal the habits or
locations of specific characters but you
can also pursue many objectives that
lead you right into the lion's den such
as playing the part of a targets golf
instructor
however it's not unusual to turn a
corner and organically cross paths with
your target they have routines and once
you realize your target is simply
following a pre-programmed path rather
than living in and reacting to the world
as a real person might their mystique
takes a nosedive this episode's
multi-stage escalation missions come in
five parts
stacking new objectives with each round
the added challenges such as not
pacifying NPCs maze completing
escalation missions more difficult with
each round but not necessarily more
enjoyable as you already know how to
complete the unchanging objectives that
persist it's possible to clear the first
few stages of an escalation mission in a
couple of minutes using the knowledge
you've gleaned from the episodes main
mission and it doesn't take long to grow
tired of walking the same paths and
resorting to the same tactics you can
look for new solutions but it's up to
you to drum up the interest in doing so
as the game doesn't go out of its way to
mix up the variables in the world to
guide you in new directions despite
having a few distinct locations to
explore within Sapienza your main
mission won't last long but the variety
is appreciated
with the lab feeling different from the
mansion feeling different than the
streets in that regard this episode
feels far more well-rounded in the first
of course the mediocre AI and animations
returned as does the need to repeat the
same old spy tricks but they take a
backseat this time around as Sapienza
and it's colorful denizens take center
stage episode tube doesn't fill your
plate but it's a satisfying experience
nonetheless
you